c'est parti on y va on va démarrer par
la nielle mots à l'oreille zidani allait
donner de précision n'est jamais jamais
tenu à afficher sa team aller annuel
allez tu perds tu sais j'ai perdu c'est
antoine et de la 3d super facile mais
très basses et des fous du cap ferret
attention tu perds tous les gens tucuman
enlevé mon alex a vogué d'ocala combien
y en a combien en tout elle a 15 ans
tout il en reste six temps qu'il entend
lever 9 bravo guillaume genton
reviennent pas non alors la deuxième
c'est au seuil et c'est merci et bravo
bientot copenhague c'est guillaume
genton qui est en finale à tokyo
castaldi castagne en matière après et
c'est un des favoris à nicolas pernikoff
joue très bien au tennis également on va
prendre les tocards toi pour l'instant
les tocards
merci après c'est moi alors il a fait
comme celle d'amener ses accents tantôt
canadien est pour l'instant si je suis
en finale s'il a fait aux boîtes gilbert
des halles et attention donc à temps et
c'est pas mal du tout ah oui pas mal du
tout donc voilà chance pour le deuxième
et il est déjà pu voir bernard c 'est
plus bas il a déjà eu assez assez assez
de malheurs de sa carrière
derrière sa cote monte elle va faire
annuler par derrière ça compte pas
jean-michel baird a jeté par terre est
au coeur oui bah oui bah oui tu respires
et je rappelle je le redis par derrière
ça ne compte pas pour tiennent mais
bravo quand même c'est bien
c'était bien dormi oui c'est génial de à
les battre parce que par contre s'ils
gagnent les annuler et on va passer
maintenant à nicolas pernikoff très
grands joueurs de débuter si on joue
très bien au tennis et quand même
pernikoff faites attention il a un fou
était un vrai bon déjà
[Rires]
[Musique]
poussan rats sera tout à l'air mais on
regarde acteurs ont régalé la nationale
10 allée castaldi ou mais ça car les son
beau ou je te cette attente en tant qu
ils sont partis alors on me dit on me
dit ah on dit quoi
on m'a dit que c'est pas bon on peut pas
être sur deux dossiers à la faute
nicolas doze il à ce que tu peux moi
plus gadget
allez on dit alors je vous le dis on va
jouer maintenant nicolas pernikoff et
moi ainsi nicolas gagne c'est bon c'est
moi qui serait le gage
ok si nicolas oui je choisis séquelles
motrices pour moi c'est nicolas père le
père d'eau
je reçois d'erreur ici qui passera tout
la première partie de l'émission sur une
chaise d'arbitré
on sait en deux ans de bac 2 points
gagnants ok c'est prêt ouais
la fête c'est pour nous faire peur voilà
tu peux la tuque après un point bas site
en touche une tumeur à pont de claix 6
pers par contre le service obligatoire
avis obligatoire
ah bah oui sinon mon frère oui mais tu
peux la veille voilà tagada tagada 3
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon tu
commences ton le deuxième point sépare
oui c'est normal mais si je serai exprès
de faire don de violence inquiète pas
que ça m'arrivera jamais mais non mais
tu es parti sur la monnaie mais j'en
attends attends attends donc on met les
boîtes et monsieur hervé témoin voilà
mon chéri parce qu'en fait on peut
penser toujours là non mais tu vas
prendre merci alex et merci co gérée par
la pensée tu l'a enlevée par la pensée
chaque joue en salle que tu ais je
rappelle que par daher ça compte pas
aller nicolas pernikoff c'est pas un
merci alex est un amour mon chéri
attention il est 18 heures 58 c'est le
before à tâtons m2 et non attends j'ai
devenu extrêmement fait repêcher
je ne me reconnais plus je vous le dis
je ne me reconnais plus
je courais niveau là il ya eu un
rochelais va y avoir une danielle le
chanteur c'est la der je souhaite tout
pour toi tu m'as balancé tu perds tu
aussi mettre à côté aussi
aussi fou
c'est avec cette enquête une arrivée ne
compte pas mais trichant sur celle du
milieu sénégalais bon égalité légalité
tout âge on attend les cherry on
rappelle que si vous nous rejoignez non
niko heu tu veux démarrer le schéma
merci les gardes tâcher de pression non
musique est oui comme on créera ces mots
comme comme c'est pas trop fort s'il a
cassé le mur à gauche à droite tu perds
ton slip et héroïque au clair sur ce
type auront lieu aux quêtes matelas
matin la faille n'y a aucune c'est quand
tu perds ton club nico tu as ton slip tu
perds ton slip dans son stop et
d'escaliers
[Applaudissements]
je vais décider celui qui va passer la
première balle à partir de l'édition sur
une chaise aride et bien écoutez je vais
vous le dire et ça me donne du mal ça
fait mal de dire ça pour qui vous êtes
daniel et moi j'aimerais voir bernard
montiel père chez delphi bernard la
halle et non parce qu'il a perdu une
hernie coffre pernikoff sera dit voilà
j'ai pas joué je m'étais péter le
poignet donc on va jouer d'accord y'a
pas de problème je joue un petit peu
comme ça j'ai au massacre est bas alors
franchement qu'ils croient personne
apatride et des chaussures de ski il
matin jusqu'à 12 ans mais ce verdict au
cefral harvey fait quand et comment à
faute
sortez moi de là j'ai ensuite les
téléspectateurs